Why are you here?
I wanted you to tell me.
You slew the dragon single-handedly.
I want to be strong like you.
How can I stop being a coward?
"Stop being a coward"?
Who said that you are a coward?
-What?
-Who said that?
The village mayor.
Live your life the way you want to,
not by someone else's ways.
I believe strength is the power
to carry this through.
Great. That's so cool, Uncle.
Mabel being like this!
Like this, Uncle must have gradually built
relationships in the other world.
How have you spent your life until now?
I have been a recluse
and closed off my heart.
That's fine.
What? But…
That's completely fine.
No matter what people said,
I never gave up being a SEGA user
and never will.
Is your role to be an ordinary citizen
who buys a popular console?
Or…
Are you sure?
Yes, I'm sure.
Incredible!
-She chose her life and went back home.
-I'm so happy to stay reclusive.
Oh, she gave me the sword.
-Please keep the god freezing sword.
-Thanks, but no thanks. It's cold.
Really?
No, I declined the offer.
Well… that's about it.
Uncle, would you care for
a bowl of soba noodles?
That's a good idea. Let's boil the water.